Have you ever left a job interview and then immediately thought, why did I say that? I have. One awkward answer, sometimes more, can suddenly become the only thing you remember. But does that mean you've blown the whole interview and does it make you a bad fit for the job? I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and this is Inner Work. Hi, welcome along to Inner Work. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, qualified clinical psychologist. Now, believe me, I quite enjoy an interview these days. I've done them live on media, on TV, I've done them on the radio, I've done them as pre-records for the TV, I've done them obviously in person for jobs, jobs that I have got and jobs that I haven't. And, you know, whilst I enjoy
你有没有过这样的经历：面试结束后，立刻心想“我刚才为什么要那样说？”我有过。一个尴尬的回答，有时甚至是多个，突然之间就成了你唯一能记住的事情。但这是否意味着你搞砸了整个面试，又是否意味着你不适合这份工作呢？我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，这是《内在工作》。嗨，欢迎来到《内在工作》。我是临床心理学家玛丽安·特伦特博士。说实话，如今我相当享受面试。我曾在媒体和电视上进行过直播面试，在电台做过面试，也录制过电视面试，当然，我也参加过面对面的求职面试，有些工作我得到了，有些则没有。而且，你知道，虽然我享受
them now, and I've always, you know, felt like I've done reasonably well at interviews, it doesn't mean that all of them have been astounding. It certainly doesn't mean that I haven't dropped some utter clangers of an answer. In my main episode this week about stress, I gave you a little unique bit of insight into a cringe-worthy thing that I said at interview. So do check that one out if you haven't already.
现在的面试，而且我一直觉得自己在面试中表现得还不错，但这并不意味着每一次面试都令人惊叹。这当然也不意味着我没有犯过那种极其愚蠢的错误。在本周关于压力的主集里，我向大家分享了一个关于我在面试中说出的令人尴尬的话的小插曲。如果你还没听过，一定要去听听那一集。
But I'm going to give you another massive clangor as well. So stay tuned for that. So, of course, when we've dropped these clangers, or even if we think we might have done reasonably well, our brains are going to focus in on that post-interview rumination, which is just like chewing the cud over and over again. And if you're anything like me, if you have dropped an interview clanger, your brain might well keep serving that up to you on replay
但我还要再告诉你一个巨大的失误。所以请继续收听。当然，当我们犯了这些错误，或者即使我们认为自己表现得还不错时，我们的大脑也会专注于面试后的反刍，这就像是在反复咀嚼反刍一样。如果你像我一样，如果你在面试中犯了错，你的大脑很可能会不断地重播那个片段，
as a little bit of added cringe. And I guess what it's trying to do there is it's trying to make sense, of it, trying to check out all the variables, trying to help you process it. But of course, we don't know what other people would have thought about that clangor. I mean, let me share another example of when it's gone really quite badly for me. So I was going to an interview as a qualified psychologist, going for an interview in a service for what's called an 8A role. And all it kind of really said about the role was that it was in IPU 10 to 17. And I was already working in children family services in what was called a CAMS service at that time.
作为一种额外的尴尬。我想它这样做是试图理解它，试图检查所有的变量，试图帮助你处理它。但当然，我们不知道别人会如何看待那个失误。我的意思是，让我分享另一个我表现得非常糟糕的例子。当时我作为一名合格的心理学家，去参加一个名为8A职位的面试。关于这个职位，它只提到是在IPU 10-17。当时我已经在儿童家庭服务部门工作，在所谓的CAMS服务部门。
And so I thought, oh, it's an inpatient unit for 10 to 17 year olds. Okay, that sounds really pretty appealing, actually. And I thought that my job skill set would be transferable from working from community services to an impatient service. And so I kind of didn't really think anything of it, really, other than to prepare some really nice kind of case study examples and obviously reference, you know, Children's Act and any kind of relevant legislation for children, young people and families. And was doing this interview and kind of, I think at one point in the interview I even said, is it possible to see the inpatient units? And they said, oh, well, they're not on site. And I thought, well, that's an unusual service because I'd worked in forensic service. and the inpatient units before, and the team would be on site where the patients are.
所以我心想，哦，这是一个针对10到17岁青少年的住院病房。好吧，听起来确实很有吸引力。我以为我的工作技能可以从社区服务转移到住院服务。所以我并没有多想，只是准备了一些非常好的案例研究示例，并引用了《儿童法》以及任何与儿童、青少年和家庭相关的法律。在面试过程中，我想在某个时候我甚至问过：“可以参观一下住院病房吗？”他们说：“哦，它们不在现场。”我想，那是一个不寻常的服务，因为我以前在法医服务部门和住院病房工作过，团队通常会和病人在同一个地方。
And I thought, well, that's odd. You'd have to, like, get in your car and visit the impatient units. That's going to make things tricky. Anyway, upshot was, I didn't get that job, but they liked me. And then I asked for feedback, and they said, we feel like you're ready for an 8A role. But we do think that you're maybe more suited to children. and adolescent and families work. And I said, oh, but I can I just check because I thought this was a children and
我觉得这很奇怪。你得开车去探访住院病房。那会让事情变得很棘手。总之，结果是我没得到那份工作，但他们喜欢我。后来我要求反馈，他们说：“我们觉得你已经准备好担任8A职位了。但我们认为你可能更适合儿童、青少年和家庭工作。”我说：“哦，但我能确认一下吗？因为我以为这是一个儿童和
adolescent and family role. And they said, what? I said, well, it's IPU 10 to 17. Isn't that an inpatient unit for 10 to 17 year old? No, they said that means integrated practice unit 10 to 17. to 17 and I said, well, what does that mean? And basically, to cut a long story short, it was the care cluster model, but nowhere on the application form, nowhere on the job description, nowhere on the person specification, did it explain what an IPU was or what the different
青少年和家庭职位。”他们说：“什么？”我说：“嗯，它是IPU 10-17。那不是10到17岁的住院病房吗？”不，他们说那是指综合实践单元（Integrated Practice Unit）10到17。我说：“那是什么意思？”简单来说，那是护理集群模型，但在申请表、职位描述或人员规范中，没有任何地方解释了什么是IPU，或者不同的
IPUs were. And so I just, you know, assumed, I guess, saw what I wanted to see and thought it was that, but it wasn't. So my first advice for interviews is just make sure you know what the terms are. Make sure you know what you're applying for because then you're less likely to get these ruminative clangers come back to you. And they said, well, that makes a lot of sense. So I offered the HR department feedback that they should be explaining what IPUs are and that did then appear on their future recruitment information. But you can't assume people know everything, especially if you don't already work for that trust.
IPU是什么。所以我只是，你知道，我猜我看到了我想看到的东西，以为是那样，但其实不是。所以我给面试的第一个建议是，确保你了解这些术语。确保你知道你在申请什么，因为这样你就不太可能遇到这些反刍式的失误。他们说：“嗯，这很有道理。”所以我向人力资源部门提供了反馈，建议他们应该解释什么是IPU，后来这确实出现在了他们未来的招聘信息中。但你不能假设每个人都知道一切，特别是如果你还没有为那个信托机构工作的话。
So I don't think that clangler was all my responsibility. But even though we might have that like real cringe-worthy moment, we are, of course, going to give the negativity bias means that we're going to pay more attention to that. But we might forget the really great 20 answers that you did give. but that one just makes you shudder and so he's attracting that negativity bias. It might not mean that you're still not appointable, just that that was a cringe moment indeed.
所以我认为那个失误并不全是我的责任。但即使我们可能会有那种非常尴尬的时刻，我们当然会因为消极偏见而更加关注它。但我们可能会忘记你给出的那20个非常棒的回答。但那一个回答只会让你不寒而栗，从而吸引了那种消极偏见。这可能并不意味着你仍然不具备被录用的资格，只是那确实是一个尴尬的时刻。
What we don't want to happen is that we become kind of catastrophizing about our own incompetence. Just because you've messed up a question or you've messed up an answer doesn't mean that you're not appropriate for this role or a similar role or that you're a horrendous. person and should never apply to a job again or that, you know, your current company would shudder if they knew how bad you'd performed. Like it doesn't mean any of those things. It just means that under pressure you didn't have the answer in that moment. And that's all we can say about that. But of course, we understand why that incompetent catastrophizing happens, because you might be comparing ourselves to others, especially if we learn that they have been able to appoint from that
我们不希望发生的是，我们开始对自己无能的表现进行灾难化思考。仅仅因为你搞砸了一个问题或回答得不好，并不意味着你不适合这个职位或类似的职位，也不意味着你是一个糟糕的人，再也不应该申请工作，或者你知道，如果你现在的公司知道你表现得有多差，他们会感到震惊。它并不意味着任何这些事情。它只是意味着在压力下，你当时没有答案。关于这一点，我们只能说这么多。但当然，我们理解为什么那种无能的灾难化思考会发生，因为你可能会把自己和别人比较，特别是当我们得知他们能够从那次
interview. Sometimes you'll even get told, oh, you were our second choice. And you're like, oh, great. You know, what feedback could I take to help make sure that I'm number one next time? But believe me, I got told a number of times I was second choice, including an example where I did get a job. They'd said that I was second choice. But the good news was they'd been able to secure another role. So they were also offering me a role. So yeah, it's not always terrible to be second. not always as bad as you think it's going to be. Sometimes, you know, keep our fingers cross, there might be more than one role. Of course, you don't really have that much control in an interview either. It's not a normalistic situation. And of course, if you are the centre
面试中录用人选时。有时你甚至会被告知：“哦，你是我们的第二选择。”你会想：“哦，太棒了。”你知道，我能从什么反馈中学习，以确保下次我是第一名？但相信我，我被告知过好几次我是第二选择，包括我确实得到了一份工作的例子。他们说我是第二选择。但好消息是他们能够确保另一个职位。所以他们也给了我一个职位。所以是的，成为第二名并不总是那么糟糕。并不总是像你想象的那么糟糕。有时，你知道，祈祷吧，可能会有不止一个职位。当然，你在面试中也没有太多的控制权。这不是一种常态化的情况。当然，如果你是
of attention, focus, you might then get in your own head a little bit. So this is not, you know, the best example of you at your most relaxed, perhaps in a meeting with a supervisor or manager that you feel comfortable with and able to kind of be comfortable. within your window of tolerance, we're always going to be probably a little bit up on the hyper arousal because of course we need a little bit of that. We can't be super laid back in interview because that might not help us to actually get to the level of attainment where we can give a good performance. But sometimes we will fluster ourselves and realise that we're not breathing, we're speaking a million miles a minute. And that's never going to help you to be
关注的焦点，你可能会有点陷入自己的思绪中。所以这并不是你最放松时的最佳表现，也许在与你感到舒适的导师或经理开会时，你能够感到自在。在我们的容忍范围内，我们可能总是会有一点过度唤醒，因为当然我们需要一点那种状态。我们在面试中不能超级放松，因为那可能无助于我们达到能够表现良好的水平。但有时我们会让自己慌乱，意识到我们没有呼吸，说话速度极快。那永远不会帮助你
on your own side. So if you notice that that was the case, then you perhaps could use that for future feedback to be like, right. I'm going to take some breaths. I'm going to slow things down and just try and make sure I'm able to, you know, to be conscious of which thoughts I am speaking aloud and how I'm coming to put together my answers for questions. So yeah, we really do want to solidify that idea that there is a difference between a candidate who gave a poor answer to a question versus a poor candidate.
站在自己这一边。所以如果你注意到是这种情况，那么你也许可以利用它作为未来的反馈，比如：“好吧，我要做几次深呼吸。我要放慢速度，尽量确保我能够意识到我正在大声说出哪些想法，以及我是如何组织我的回答的。”所以是的，我们确实想巩固这样一个观点：给出一个糟糕回答的候选人与一个糟糕的候选人之间是有区别的。
because the two things are not necessarily the same and in fact you can give a whole doozie of a whole interview where you just feel like it was horrendous that it doesn't make you a bad candidate when I sat my driving test for the third time I made a mistake at a roundabout and instead of going on the second left which was straight over I went left and so I thought oh I've messed up now you know I've failed another test but when I got to the end of the test, I'd actually passed. And I said, well, how did I pass when I went in the wrong way? And the examiner said, because you indicated left and then went left. So even though you thought you'd not followed the route because you didn't, and it meant
因为这两件事并不一定是一回事，事实上，你可以进行一场糟糕透顶的面试，让你觉得非常可怕，但这并不会让你成为一个糟糕的候选人。当我第三次参加驾驶考试时，我在一个环岛处犯了一个错误，我没有走第二个左转出口（即直行），而是向左转了，所以我心想：“哦，我搞砸了，你知道，我又没通过考试。”但当我到达考试终点时，我实际上通过了。我说：“我走错了路，怎么会通过呢？”考官说：“因为你打了左转向灯，然后向左转了。”所以即使你认为你没有按照路线行驶，因为你确实没有，这意味着
that we had to kind of adopt a slightly different route, you then drove really well. I think I only got a couple of minors. So because I'd taken the pressure off myself, because I thought it hadn't done. done very well, that then allowed me to kind of, you know, thrive and ultimately pass. And so it might be that if you've kind of given a little bit of an answer that's made you cringe, maybe that might help you to then kind of think, well, how bad can this get, you know, and then, you know, optimize your performance throughout the rest of the interview. What can you do after an interview when you feel like it hasn't gone very well?
我们不得不采取稍微不同的路线，但你随后开得非常好。我想我只得了几个轻微扣分。所以因为我减轻了自己的压力，因为我以为我没做好，这反而让我能够，你知道，茁壮成长并最终通过。所以如果你给出的回答让你感到尴尬，也许这能帮助你思考：“好吧，情况能有多糟糕呢？”然后，你知道，优化你在面试其余部分的表现。面试后如果你觉得表现得不太好，你能做什么？
Well, I will always, even whether I think an interview has gone well or not well, I will tend to jot it down as a bit of a reflection afterwards. The things that I thought went well, the things that I thought needed improvement, the bits where I felt I was really proud of myself and the areas for learning. I think this can be really helpful, especially when it comes to like trauma processing, because it allows you to go from A to B to C to D to E to F, rather than like A to P to P to A. to V, like, you know, through the highlights of the bits that felt really awful. So what we're doing, we write an account is we're kind of helping to process, knock the edges off, and it then can mean that we stop resetting, you know, the awful bits of the interview and we get things balanced up a little bit better. What about that embarrassment?
嗯，我总是，无论我认为面试进行得好还是不好，我都会在事后把它记下来作为一种反思。我认为做得好的地方，我认为需要改进的地方，我感到非常自豪的部分以及需要学习的领域。我认为这非常有帮助，特别是在处理创伤时，因为它允许你从A到B到C到D到E到F，而不是像A到P到P到A到V，你知道，通过那些感觉非常糟糕的片段的亮点。所以我们正在做的是，我们写下一份记录，我们是在帮助处理它，磨掉棱角，这可能意味着我们停止重置面试中糟糕的部分，我们能更好地平衡事情。那尴尬感呢？
What about that cringe? I think it can be helpful to use that as information. That can show you that there was a knowledge gap or that you weren't able to retry to the knowledge. You know, maybe like me, you've got a bit of perimenopause, or maybe you were just really tired, or you were hungry, or you were stressed because you couldn't find a parking space and you're worried you're going to be late. For whatever reason, you had an inability to get out an answer which might have scored more highly. And that can be information for the next time you have an interview. So maybe I'll make sure that maybe if it's a distance away, maybe I'll say
那尴尬感呢？我认为利用它作为信息是有帮助的。这可以向你展示存在知识差距，或者你无法调取知识。你知道，也许像我一样，你有点围绝经期症状，或者也许你只是真的很累，或者你饿了，或者你因为找不到停车位而感到压力，担心会迟到。无论出于什么原因，你无法给出一个得分更高的答案。这可以成为你下次面试的信息。所以也许我会确保，如果距离很远，也许我会说
if I can stay overnight nearby, or I can make sure that I leave early enough that I'm getting there in good time and I'm parked or make sure that I Google any of the complicated terms I'm not 100% sure on so that every time over time it minimises and reduces the chance that I won't be the best candidate for that interview next time. So we're really using that embarrassment as information not punishment. Similarly we're going to employ some self-compassion. And if you'd like to learn more about self-compassion, who better to learn it from than Professor Paul Gilbert who I was very lucky to speak to for two episodes of the podcast episode 200 and episode 201 so do check those out when you have a
如果我能住在附近，或者我可以确保我早点出发，这样我能及时到达并停好车，或者确保我用谷歌搜索任何我不百分之百确定的复杂术语，这样随着时间的推移，它会最小化并减少我下次在面试中表现不佳的可能性。所以我们确实是在利用那种尴尬作为信息，而不是惩罚。同样，我们将采用一些自我同情。如果你想了解更多关于自我同情的知识，还有谁比保罗·吉尔伯特教授更适合学习呢？我很幸运能为播客的第200集和第201集采访他，所以当你
chance so self-compassion is a really really important thing to adopt especially if you are striving for any particular careers because ultimately we'll need to stay on our own team you know it's not it's not it's not going to be helpful if you're constantly tearing yourself down criticizing you, belittling yourself. Like, ultimately, that's not cool. That's not, that's not keeping on your own team. So, you know, compassionate reframe might be, I was under pressure, and as a result, I answered imperfectly or not to the standards I usually would hope to strive for. And that doesn't make me an idiot, that just makes me a human. And again, like another compassionate
有机会时一定要去看看。所以自我同情是一个非常非常重要的事情，特别是如果你正在追求任何特定的职业，因为最终我们需要站在自己的团队中。你知道，如果你不断地拆台、批评自己、贬低自己，那一点帮助都没有。最终，那并不酷。那不是站在自己这一边。所以，你知道，同情的重构可能是：“我在压力之下，因此，我回答得不完美，或者没有达到我通常希望努力达到的标准。”这并不意味着我是个白痴，这只是意味着我是一个人类。再说一次，另一个同情的
at Reframe was like, had I known the IPU 10 to 17 wasn't an inpatient unit, then I would have done something differently. I would have done the interview differently. But also, I do have that sense of what's for you, won't pass you by. That's my own kind of personal sense. And I never really wanted to work in psychosis. I don't even know that I would have applied for a role in psychosis. So, you know, it ended up working out well because I ended up. up getting an interview in a different IPU, three to eight. I think I would have got a clue that that was maybe not three to eight because who has children as young as three, an inpatient unit unless it's a maternal mental health unit or a family unit. But yeah, 10 to 17,
重构就像是：“如果我知道IPU 10-17不是住院病房，那么我会做些不同的事情。我会以不同的方式进行面试。”但同时，我也有一种“是你的终究是你的”的感觉。这是我个人的感觉。我从来没想过要在精神病学领域工作。我甚至不知道我是否会申请精神病学领域的职位。所以，你知道，结果还不错，因为我最终在另一个IPU 3-8得到了面试机会。我想我会明白那可能不是3-8，因为谁会有像3岁那么小的孩子在住院病房，除非是母婴心理健康单元或家庭单元。但是的，10-17，
I thought, well, that's convincing. That's doable. But yeah, I did ultimately get that job in the other service that I actually was a really good fit for and really enjoyed. So You know, there was no harm done. And whilst it is cringy right now, sometimes it can be useful, right? If these things hadn't happened to me, I wouldn't be able to share them with you, and then that wouldn't make you feel better about yourself, right?
我想，嗯，这很有说服力。这是可行的。但是的，我最终确实得到了那个我确实非常适合并且非常享受的另一项服务的工作。所以，你知道，没有造成任何伤害。虽然现在很尴尬，但有时它可能是有用的，对吧？如果这些事情没有发生在我身上，我就无法与你分享，那也就不会让你对自己感觉好一点，对吧？
Validation is important, it matters. And one day you might be able to tell a story about your quingy interview moments, and you might even get the job anyway. Will you let me know in the comments, Whether you're watching on Spotify or YouTube, you can drop me episode-specific comments. Let me know what your interview horrors were and what sense you made of it. They can't be any worse than mine, right?
验证很重要，它很重要。总有一天，你也许能讲出关于你尴尬面试时刻的故事，而且你甚至可能还是得到了那份工作。你能在评论中告诉我吗？无论你是在Spotify还是YouTube上观看，你都可以给我留下特定于剧集的评论。告诉我你的面试恐怖经历以及你是如何理解它的。它们不可能比我的更糟，对吧？
I've got another one too that I've remembered, but I'm trying to keep this video short. So maybe let me know if you'd like another video on interviews, and I can cover that one there. So you're absolutely able to have one or two bad interviews without it, meaning that you're a bad person and that you're not a good fit for the role. And you're also allowed to learn from your experiences without turning it into evidence that you're not good enough. So stay on your own team and I'm here for you. If you are happening to watch or listen to this because you're an aspiring psychologist and you'd like to up your game in interviews, why not consider accessing the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can do from just £30 a month with no minimum term.
我还记得另一个，但我正试图让这个视频简短一些。所以也许让我知道你是否想要另一个关于面试的视频，我可以在那里涵盖那个。所以你完全可以有一次或两次糟糕的面试，而不意味着你是一个糟糕的人，也不意味着你不适合这个职位。你也可以从你的经历中学习，而不必把它变成你不够好的证据。所以站在自己这一边，我在这里支持你。如果你碰巧因为你是一个有抱负的心理学家而观看或收听这个节目，并且你想在面试中提升你的水平，为什么不考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”呢？每月只需30英镑，没有最低期限。
We have over four and a half years of replay content, including interview replay content. And that's at the time of recording. by the time this is live, it will be even more. So dive in. Let me know if you've got any questions. Come and follow me wherever you are on social media. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. I think you'll really enjoy those episodes I did with Professor Paul Gilbert,
我们有超过四年半的重播内容，包括面试重播内容。这是在录制时的数据。到这个节目上线时，内容会更多。所以深入了解一下吧。如果你有任何问题，请告诉我。无论你在哪里，都来关注我的社交媒体。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我想你会非常喜欢我和保罗·吉尔伯特教授做的那些剧集，
which are episodes 200 and 201. Details in the show notes. And I look forward to bringing you the next episode of Inner Work, wherever you get your podcasts and on YouTube from Wednesday at 8pm UK time. Stay kind to yourself. I'll see you soon. Take care. You know, There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
分别是第200集和第201集。详情在节目说明中。我期待着在周三英国时间晚上8点，通过你获取播客的任何平台以及YouTube，为你带来下一集《内在工作》。对自己好一点。很快再见。保重。你知道，这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。